Caption: our next speaker is Troy Gerwin his talk
Caption: is on the limits of my programming
Caption: language meaning the limits mean the
Caption: limits of my world Troy is a software
Caption: engineer with broad industrial
Caption: experience and he's currently developing
Caption: games at vgw he maintains he also
Caption: maintains and contributes to several
Caption: open source projects and is a mentor at
Caption: Coda dijo
Caption: Troy is interested in what makes
Caption: software great not just for the user but
Caption: also for the team maintaining it a big
Caption: welcome to Troy
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thanks for that introduction thanks
Caption: everyone for for coming and also of
Caption: course thanks to the sponsors who've
Caption: made this whole thing possible and also
Caption: the volunteers and the organizers
Caption: um one other thing uh to remember about
Caption: DDD is that it's a democracy and that's
Caption: a cool thing right but you know what the
Caption: problem is with democracy sometimes
Caption: candidates make promises to get voted in
Caption: and then they find that they can't
Caption: deliver on their promises so when DDD
Caption: called for submissions I was just
Caption: thinking like what would be a cool talk
Caption: what would be something interesting to
Caption: go to and I just sort of thought of this
Caption: um there was a phrase that was popping
Caption: up and I googled and I found okay was
Caption: this phrase by Wittgenstein philosopher
Caption: and he said the limits of my language
Caption: mean the limits of my world and I
Caption: thought wow that'd be an interesting
Caption: thing to think about with programming
Caption: languages like are we actually stopping
Caption: ourselves from doing a better job as a
Caption: software industry because of limits in
Caption: our programming language not being able
Caption: to come up with better Solutions or or
Caption: less buggy Solutions so I just shoved
Caption: one word in there and I thought okay
Caption: that's a nice catchy title all I need to
Caption: do now is come up with a pitch and
Caption: here's like a little summarized version
Caption: if you don't remember it but I'm just
Caption: saying like you know badly designed
Caption: programming language is thought
Caption: Inhibitors are they part of the reason
Caption: why we ship projects late and
Caption: um and and with flaws so that's as far
Caption: as I went unfortunately I delivered the
Caption: promise but I didn't actually stop to
Caption: think of what it would take to to
Caption: actually fulfill the promise so when my
Caption: talk actually got selected I started to
Caption: think about what the content would be be
Caption: for this talk and I thought oh crap
Caption: anyway it's too late to change the pitch
Caption: at that point
Caption: and I didn't want to do a bait and
Caption: switch because there's a lot of depth
Caption: and a lot of breadth to this topic it
Caption: turns out so I could either just fly
Caption: over the you know
Caption: fly over the landscape and not really
Caption: give much detail anywhere or I could
Caption: Deep dive into one thing but then I
Caption: really feel like I'd be breaking my
Caption: promise which was to sort of cover it a
Caption: bit more broadly in early feedback I
Caption: gave this talk earlier a draft version
Caption: of this and I got some really cool
Caption: feedback and someone said this talk
Caption: title could be the title of a whole Tech
Caption: conference you could have a whole Tech
Caption: conference about this and then people
Caption: would go to the individual talks and
Caption: focus on the different areas and I
Caption: thought that's a cool idea and it
Caption: actually gave me a way of thinking about
Caption: what this talk that you've come to would
Caption: be this talk would be the keynote so
Caption: imagine that we've got a whole whole day
Caption: to talk about this topic and this this
Caption: talk then just means I can just kind of
Caption: like go at 10 000 meters over the
Caption: landscape and just maybe point out a few
Caption: little details here and there knowing
Caption: that you know that's something that you
Caption: can follow up in a you know in detail in
Caption: another area all I can do is really just
Caption: give it five minutes and just cover a
Caption: whole lot of things
Caption: um so just at this high level we're
Caption: talking about programming languages and
Caption: I thought that this this is a quote from
Caption: a really great introductory textbook on
Caption: functional programming uh by a couple of
Caption: guys who are really influential in the
Caption: ml community and developing camel in
Caption: particular uh and they said the
Caption: programming language we use influences
Caption: our capacity as programmers to produce
Caption: correct programs within a reasonable
Caption: period of time and
Caption: something implied in this we're not
Caption: talking about there's no problem with
Caption: Express being able to express Solutions
Caption: we can express Solutions most of you
Caption: have probably heard of during
Caption: completeness it just means if
Caption: something's true and complete you can
Caption: compute absolutely anything that is
Caption: computable with with that device or that
Caption: language or whatever it is and it's
Caption: actually surprisingly low bar
Caption: redstone blocks in Minecraft that you're
Caption: incomplete Excel spreadsheets are
Caption: cheering complete I just found out at a
Caption: previous talk I went to that PowerPoint
Caption: slides are cheering complete you could
Caption: you could build your line of business
Caption: application as a as a deck of PowerPoint
Caption: slides if you really wanted to
Caption: um but we don't do that because the two
Caption: real key things are not can you build it
Caption: it's that can you build it in a
Caption: reasonable period of time and with few
Caption: enough defects so these are the the two
Caption: really important things so just to
Caption: summarize those two things I've just
Caption: used the words convenience and
Caption: correctness so these are kind of like
Caption: the the themes that will come back again
Caption: and again
Caption: um
Caption: the pictures you might be wondering what
Caption: that's all about I went to another
Caption: conference the other day that my work
Caption: put on and I just heard this phrase
Caption: dragons and rabbit holes and I thought
Caption: hey that kind of applies so dragons like
Caption: on the edge of the map there'd be
Caption: dragons right they're the things you
Caption: want to avoid the bugs the the undefined
Caption: behavior in your program so that's
Caption: that's correctness
Caption: rabbit holes is when in the context of
Caption: programming languages it's really
Caption: difficult to figure out how do I express
Caption: the the problem that I'm trying to solve
Caption: in the language the language maybe it
Caption: gives you no clear ways to do it and
Caption: you've got to build up all this stuff
Caption: yourself or you're out there searching
Caption: through half a dozen libraries that give
Caption: you different trade-offs and so on so
Caption: convenience is about how what's a
Caption: reasonable amount of time to be able to
Caption: come up with a good solution and how
Caption: maintainable is that solution so these
Caption: are the two sort of overarching themes
Caption: that we come across
Caption: um just to briefly go on those actually
Caption: I I think for time I won't go into
Caption: details but some of you may have heard
Caption: of this appear Wharf hypothesis so
Caption: convenience is really about this idea
Caption: that that limits in what language you
Caption: what your language can express mean you
Caption: know limits in what you can actually do
Caption: so it's language as a thought tool it
Caption: can basically multiply your powers or it
Caption: could divide your powers
Caption: um so this is the effort to express
Caption: requirements as a as a program using a
Caption: programming language so the the general
Caption: thing with convenience is that we seem
Caption: to be suggesting that we want more
Caption: flexibility and we want Rich language
Caption: because that's going to make it more
Caption: convenient on the other side correctness
Caption: the safety of being able to express
Caption: things in a program uh the the set of
Caption: possible programs that exist out there
Caption: is huge right probably infinite
Caption: definitely infinite but a lot of those
Caption: programs that we could possibly Express
Caption: they're subtly wrong they might be
Caption: almost the right solution but not choir
Caption: but we can still Express them so this
Caption: sort of implies that we want less
Caption: expressiveness we want to basically cut
Caption: off Avenues towards expressing programs
Caption: that are wrong that are subtly wrong
Caption: um if for example some some programming
Caption: languages allow you to express memory
Caption: management explicitly but they introduce
Caption: the dangers because of that because they
Caption: allow you to express all the incorrect
Caption: patterns of memory management as well on
Caption: the other hand you've got languages like
Caption: Java or c-sharp that have automatic
Caption: memory management you cannot express
Caption: memory management patterns it doesn't
Caption: let you do it it just does it
Caption: automatically so it's less expressive
Caption: but it's more correct
Caption: so if this was a fictional conference PL
Caption: conf 22 this would be the the billing of
Caption: the talks so I'm going to talk just
Caption: briefly about a bunch of topics here
Caption: basically some fundamentals at the
Caption: beginning
Caption: um this General theme that I want to
Caption: bring out that programming languages are
Caption: for humans and then a couple of deep
Caption: Dives at the end
Caption: all right getting started on the first
Caption: one
Caption: um
Caption: just about motivation
Caption: why would we care about programming
Caption: language design does it really matter in
Caption: the real world so
Caption: Mark Anderson about 10 years ago put out
Caption: a an article that was quite well known
Caption: Wall Street Journal software is eating
Caption: the world and he was just pointing out
Caption: how we've just got this unprecedented
Caption: and growing Global dependence on
Caption: software systems there's some just look
Caption: at the companies that I've listed there
Caption: think about what they've how they've
Caption: transformed our economy so bookshops
Caption: Amazon comes along the the global book
Caption: industry is now basically a software
Caption: industry uh Uber Uber doesn't have taxis
Caption: they don't have their own drivers
Caption: they're basically they have an app and
Caption: they have a bunch of software running on
Caption: the back end and and that's the the
Caption: global company
Caption: so more and more of the global economy
Caption: is actually software it's built and and
Caption: runs off both software so this also
Caption: implies that there's these growing and
Caption: huge risk and reward multipliers because
Caption: so much of what of our economic everyday
Caption: activity is mediated through software so
Caption: if you can increase the convenience of
Caption: being able to create that software more
Caption: quickly or more reliably you might have
Caption: a great competitive Advantage
Caption: equally if you can improve the
Caption: correctness because of new patterns in
Caption: in programming languages that just you
Caption: know block off Avenues of expressing
Caption: bugs you might experience less hacks
Caption: less exploits and less failures which is
Caption: also going to be good so I'm not
Caption: suggesting that programming languages
Caption: are the only problem for improving our
Caption: productivity with software they're
Caption: probably not even the major factor
Caption: because we've got people and we've got
Caption: processes and that's usually where you
Caption: look if you want to make things more
Caption: efficient
Caption: um but I I don't think it's zero I think
Caption: that I what I'd like to demonstrate
Caption: today is that programming languages
Caption: themselves can shift the needle on
Caption: things that are actually important in
Caption: the real world
Caption: um and even if it's a small amount we're
Caption: talking a huge numbers here right so
Caption: it's still a huge number
Caption: so the question is what about these
Caption: numbers like are we doing fine as a
Caption: software industry or aren't we so it's
Caption: not hard to actually just like troll the
Caption: internet and look for example look for
Caption: studies I just listed a whole bunch here
Caption: I'm not going to go through all of these
Caption: but just you can see the the general
Caption: size of the numbers so the capital t is
Caption: trillion
Caption: um there's studies there that are just
Caption: estimating the cost of software failures
Caption: in the us alone at something like two
Caption: trillion dollars a year which is like 10
Caption: of the economy even if the estimates are
Caption: way off even if they're vaguely in the
Caption: ballpark it's there we're talking really
Caption: huge numbers there's lots of other
Caption: things there that are easy to find if
Caption: you're interested there's also really
Caption: interesting individual examples and I'll
Caption: just highlight this thorac 25 back in
Caption: the 80s it was a medical device I
Caption: believe for taking X-rays of patients
Caption: and injuries and deaths were involved so
Caption: that was a combined Hardware Software
Caption: System that they wrote their own
Caption: software for that system the company
Caption: that released it it had preemptive
Caption: multitasking it was was basically
Caption: written in Assembly Language and it also
Caption: had mutable shared state so the language
Caption: they were using didn't protect against
Caption: any of those things it was all up to the
Caption: the programmers to be able to spot their
Caption: own errors and in all their test Suites
Caption: everything worked fine because they
Caption: tested it in test conditions had no
Caption: problems eventually they actually
Caption: injured and killed a number of people
Caption: because certain operators using that
Caption: machine typed a bit too fast at the
Caption: wrong time and that triggered a race
Caption: condition in their code and they didn't
Caption: admit it for a long time because they
Caption: couldn't reproduce it but that was
Caption: definitely an issue that could be
Caption: resolved with a different choice of
Caption: programming language
Caption: so that's just one example and there's
Caption: others there as well
Caption: um it's also easy to come across
Caption: articles like this so Microsoft did an
Caption: internal study and found that 70 of
Caption: their security bugs are memory safety
Caption: issues and in that article they
Caption: particularly highlight that a lot of the
Caption: software involves written in CNC plus
Caption: plus
Caption: memory unsafe languages where one slip
Caption: up in the developers memory management
Caption: code can lead to a slew of memory safety
Caption: error errors that attackers can exploit
Caption: with dangerous and intrusive
Caption: consequences so that's really cheating
Caption: home
Caption: consequences directly to the programming
Caption: language Choice itself
Caption: so just to sum up that section
Caption: programming language design definitely
Caption: does have real world consequences
Caption: another one of these topics that we
Caption: would fly over in this conference would
Caption: be that there's never going to be one
Caption: programming language to rule them all
Caption: wouldn't it it'd be nice right
Caption: um but well
Caption: here's a picture of uh each of those
Caption: little words it doesn't matter they're
Caption: too small to read but they're all names
Caption: of programming languages and the little
Caption: lines between them basically Trace
Caption: influence and we're going down the page
Caption: so we're back in the 70s up the top and
Caption: we're down to a few years ago at the
Caption: bottom
Caption: um anyway I don't know about you but I
Caption: don't really see much sense of
Caption: convergence in here it's and also it
Caption: seems like ideas have been around for a
Caption: long time and they influence and they
Caption: they go away they come back so consensus
Caption: in programming languages doesn't seem to
Caption: really be there so why is that it's not
Caption: for lack of trying so
Caption: the the current candidate for the one
Caption: programming language to rule them all in
Caption: many people's view is is Javascript and
Caption: Atwood even made law about well what he
Caption: claimed you know to be a law that
Caption: anything that can be written in
Caption: JavaScript will eventually be written in
Caption: JavaScript and on the far side on my um
Caption: on the right hand side there uh it
Caption: probably too small to read but it just
Caption: gives you a glimpse this is the tc39
Caption: committee that decides what things are
Caption: going to make it into the next version
Caption: of JavaScript and pretty much everyone
Caption: this is this is like a third of just
Caption: what fits on a screen it goes down and
Caption: these are only stage one proposals they
Caption: also have stage zero stage one two three
Caption: and then four means it's in the language
Caption: so basically every everybody is trying
Caption: to get the language to do their thing so
Caption: you know it's not like we don't want
Caption: there to be one language to rule them
Caption: all
Caption: um this is not new so Tony Hawk who gave
Caption: us quick sort um he also gave us nulls
Caption: the billion dollar mistake uh he's a
Caption: quote from a paper that he wrote he was
Caption: it says we were charged with the
Caption: standardization of a language to end all
Caption: languages designed to meet the needs of
Caption: all Computer Applications both social
Caption: and scientific and that was in the 1960s
Caption: in reference to pli which most of you
Caption: including me have probably never even
Caption: seen let alone worked on so I guess that
Caption: didn't work out either
Caption: the problem really comes down to the
Caption: fact that there's competing goals in
Caption: programming language design so I'm not
Caption: going to go through all of these but
Caption: just to give you an idea there's just
Caption: some I just ham it out just I think a
Caption: lot of them would be make sense but I'll
Caption: give you one illustration so going back
Caption: to this example with memory safety
Caption: that's relevant here so some trade-offs
Caption: here so for example if you were you had
Caption: a fresh new application you need to
Caption: develop and you're trying to choose
Caption: which language to use
Caption: um if you had absolute real-time
Caption: performance requirements where you
Caption: cannot stand garbage collection pauses
Caption: let's say so you're on the side of
Caption: having to have absolute performance
Caption: there is a trade-off there in the sense
Caption: that you probably wouldn't want to use
Caption: Java and c-sharp because they do
Caption: automatic memory management at the cost
Caption: of some stuttering some pauses and just
Caption: unpredictable performance so you would
Caption: probably want to go on the C plus or
Caption: rust side because you can actually
Caption: literally control the memory management
Caption: in the programming language itself
Caption: on the other hand is there a trade-off
Caption: let's say at the bottom between
Caption: um Java and rust so if if we choose rust
Caption: because it's really safe with memory why
Caption: why wouldn't we always choose rust well
Caption: maybe performance isn't the the top
Caption: thing maybe it's just speed of
Caption: development and um I'm not a super
Caption: proficient rust developer but having
Caption: looked around I can see that you know a
Caption: lot of people say it's not that
Caption: straightforward to satisfy the borrow
Caption: Checker you've got to do it you've got
Caption: to really understand what you're doing
Caption: in a non-trivial application so why
Caption: would you even put that barrier in front
Caption: of your team of software developers if
Caption: absolute real-time performance wasn't an
Caption: issue maybe you're just developing a a
Caption: simple app for your own use or I don't
Caption: know there's lots of situations where
Caption: you might not have that requirement so
Caption: there's a trade-off there it's it's
Caption: harder to get the thing up and running
Caption: and shipped in Rust than it would be in
Caption: Java and C sharp so it really depends on
Caption: whether you have that performance
Caption: requirement or not so that's just some
Caption: examples of trade-offs okay moving on
Caption: um this section would be about
Caption: essential and accidental complexity so
Caption: this concept came from Fred Brooks
Caption: Brooks who gave us the book The Mythical
Caption: man month so back in the 80s he also
Caption: wrote this paper called No Silver Bullet
Caption: and he he gave us this nice way of
Caption: thinking about software systems as uh
Caption: having two kinds of complexity in them
Caption: essential complexity and accidental
Caption: complexity so essential complexity in
Caption: software is basically the stuff you
Caption: can't get rid of because it's the spec
Caption: it's like here here's the spec please go
Caption: and Implement a program that does this
Caption: that does what it says so if it's in the
Caption: spec and the Spec's complicated That's
Caption: essential complexity if it says you've
Caption: got to do those 25 things you've got to
Caption: do those 25 things if it says you have
Caption: to interface with three wildly
Caption: incompatible terribly written external
Caption: systems that's an essential thing
Caption: because that's what's in the spec right
Caption: so you can't avoid it
Caption: accidental complexity on the other hand
Caption: is stuff that still makes it difficult
Caption: and complex they're just basically
Caption: unhelpful barriers to expressing a
Caption: working solution but they're not
Caption: inherent in the spec so for example
Caption: manual memory management if you're
Caption: thinking about managing your memory but
Caption: the spec just says well we need this
Caption: this mobile app for the customer that's
Caption: accidental complexity it's just
Caption: something you you have to do on top of
Caption: solving the the essential problem and
Caption: choosing different tools can affect how
Caption: much accidental complexity makes up the
Caption: the overall complexity of your job
Caption: so
Caption: essential complexity sounds like
Caption: something you can't get rid of I just
Caption: wanted to briefly mention that it's not
Caption: actually true you can reduce essential
Caption: complexity but with another trade-off so
Caption: if you think about domain specific
Caption: languages or even visual programming
Caption: languages they tend to be reduce
Caption: essential complexity by allowing you to
Caption: to state things at a higher level you
Caption: can quickly say how you want things to
Caption: be done so for example SQL for data
Caption: access so we don't write python
Caption: generally for doing database queries on
Caption: a relational database we write SQL and
Caption: it's really quick and it gets the job
Caption: done but it's basically a domain
Caption: specific language or a DSL for that one
Caption: job so it sacrifices generality but it
Caption: means you can do that one job well so
Caption: that's great there's languages that do
Caption: things regex would be another example
Caption: there's there's lots of them but they
Caption: don't solve the general problem it's not
Caption: like if you're given a brief that you've
Caption: got to develop a whole app you go for
Caption: the specific DSL there probably isn't
Caption: one in most cases you need a general
Caption: language so you can't always make this
Caption: trade-off
Caption: um on the other hand accidental
Caption: complexity so we still you know there's
Caption: things like boilerplate code if you have
Caption: to if you're writing your app if you
Caption: have to think about managing memory
Caption: yourself or managing concurrency
Caption: managing dependencies managing versions
Caption: these aren't things that are in the spec
Caption: they're just things that you've got to
Caption: get right and they just they're just
Caption: unhelpful barriers that get in your way
Caption: um Brooks in no Silver Bullet
Caption: interestingly says we've already solved
Caption: The Accidental complexity problem for
Caption: the most part that's that was his view
Caption: back in the 1980s
Caption: um I don't know if any of you have can
Caption: think of what he said was the number one
Caption: thing that made the biggest difference
Caption: in accident in solving accidental
Caption: complexity
Caption: so
Caption: the thing that made the biggest
Caption: difference was in his View High Level
Caption: language so high level language just
Caption: means now there's something we
Caption: completely take for granted when you
Caption: write program code in in any programming
Caption: language that we use today pretty much
Caption: you are writing code using for example
Caption: English keywords it's human
Caption: understandable it's written in a high
Caption: level you can kind of see that the loops
Caption: and the conditions in the code and it's
Caption: translated down to something that the
Caption: machine can understand so that's what we
Caption: mean by highly High language high level
Caption: language it's that the code is
Caption: independent of the machine that is going
Caption: to run it the the specific things the
Caption: machine has to do they're not
Caption: represented there in the language that's
Caption: high-level language
Caption: he estimates that that gave us a five
Caption: times productivity boost so I thought it
Caption: would be interesting rather than just
Caption: you know five times what does that mean
Caption: you know we don't really think about it
Caption: right but I'd like us to actually think
Caption: what it was like for our compatriots
Caption: software developers back in the day
Caption: before high level languages just to give
Caption: you an idea of how important accidental
Caption: complexity can actually be so what were
Caption: they doing well first example this is
Caption: something that I personally remember
Caption: because I had a Commodore 64 when I was
Caption: a kid and no money so rather than being
Caption: able to go and buy all the cool games
Caption: off the shelf sometimes we'd come across
Caption: a magazine and it would say type the
Caption: game in yourself so it just sounds
Caption: awesome when you're a kid when you read
Caption: the description space Blaster this is
Caption: going to be so awesome like it's
Caption: action-packed and everything like that
Caption: but then you've got to write this out
Caption: yourself and you can see there's a few
Caption: lines of basic at the top that's
Caption: bootstrapping but pretty much the whole
Caption: game is actually in machine language for
Caption: the 6502 CPU inside the Commodore 64 and
Caption: you have to specify it byte by byte as
Caption: these like
Caption: um
Caption: hex codes the other thing is if you get
Caption: any of those wrong if you get one letter
Caption: wrong one character wrong in any of that
Caption: well if you're lucky you've probably
Caption: just screwed up a Sprite and it's you
Caption: know the colors are mixed up in
Caption: somewhere but more likely most of that
Caption: will be control flow and Logic for the
Caption: game and if you just basically change a
Caption: bite there all bets are off you probably
Caption: crashed your machine lock it up or who
Caption: knows it probably won't be the fun space
Caption: Blaster experience you're hoping for
Caption: um going back even before that they had
Caption: even extra steps you know they'd fill
Caption: out these punched cards so I won't go
Caption: too much into that that's really going
Caption: back but I think you get the idea that
Caption: there was a lot of accidental complexity
Caption: involved in developing software back
Caption: then you've got to think at a really low
Caption: level
Caption: um the other thing is there's pretty
Caption: much no protection from errors because
Caption: the way there's no interpretation step
Caption: what you present to the computer it goes
Caption: well this is what this must be what you
Caption: meant I'll just try and execute it so
Caption: basically I like to think of that as a
Caption: cosmic ray on your on your punch card
Caption: give just gives you a new program as far
Caption: as the computer is concerned oh okay
Caption: every program that you give me is what I
Caption: think you meant and it just executes
Caption: differently
Caption: um so a little a little taste of that
Caption: 6502 this was the CPU inside the
Caption: Commodore 64 and also the Apple II I've
Caption: got like six bytes of machine code at
Caption: the top there and that decompiles into
Caption: these Assembly Language instructions
Caption: it's just a little Loop it just starts
Caption: at 255 and it counts down to zero and
Caption: then and then it returns so that's all
Caption: it does what I'm going to do is on that
Caption: last bite I'm just going to change the
Caption: 60 to a 61. it's one bit it's just
Caption: changing one bit so watch watch down the
Caption: bottom
Caption: and now instead of returning from the
Caption: instruction I'm doing some further
Caption: arithmetic and I'm not returning and
Caption: whatever comes after that is what is
Caption: what the process is going to keep doing
Caption: it's a good example that's probably just
Caption: going to lock up your machine
Caption: um yeah I had to restart my computer a
Caption: lot of times
Caption: um just another example so now I'm just
Caption: going to transpose the the two parts of
Caption: the third byte so instead of CA it's
Caption: going to be AC and we can watch down the
Caption: bottom again and now I've got pretty
Caption: much a completely different program
Caption: there's now no loop at all and it also
Caption: still doesn't return so you're going to
Caption: get a vastly different outcome and I
Caption: just changed a couple of bits the
Caption: program looks the same so that's all
Caption: accidental complexity
Caption: um just a bonus question to end this
Caption: section can anyone think of any language
Caption: that we still use very commonly probably
Caption: most software developers in this room
Caption: have have used at some point that has
Caption: some of these characteristics that I've
Caption: just been describing
Caption: yep
Caption: yes yes
Caption: exactly regex I like to call it a
Caption: write-only language
Caption: um
Caption: see if you can think of what this regex
Caption: does I I won't call for volunteers but
Caption: I'll just tell you it's it actually
Caption: parses or validates email addresses
Caption: that's not obvious from looking at it so
Caption: the way you would come up with that is
Caption: you'd think at a high level okay what
Caption: are the parts of an email address and
Caption: you translate it down into this kind of
Caption: almost like machine language and then if
Caption: you ever try and want to know what that
Caption: does again I would probably just copy it
Caption: and paste it into one of those websites
Caption: that sort of decompiles a regex for you
Caption: and gives you a visualization it's not
Caption: that different from what they were doing
Caption: back in the day so yeah we still have
Caption: this
Caption: okay Moving On Again
Caption: Now we move into this section where I'm
Caption: really focusing on the human aspect of
Caption: programming language design
Caption: we don't want to overburden the human
Caption: why is that well
Caption: I'm just going to start with this quote
Caption: from Donald knuth he's pointing out that
Caption: programming is the art of telling
Caption: another human being
Caption: what one wants the computer to do
Caption: programming languages aren't for the
Caption: machine they're for people if if
Caption: programming languages were for the
Caption: machine we'd still be programming in
Caption: Assembly Language or machine language
Caption: because that's the easiest thing for the
Caption: machine to process the reason why we use
Caption: these high-level languages and then all
Caption: these very sophisticated tools to
Caption: translate that down to the machine is
Caption: that the source code of programs is for
Caption: us it's for humans
Caption: so if you think about what scarce in the
Caption: production of software it's definitely
Caption: like making more copies of it it's free
Caption: to make more copies of software like all
Caption: the the raw materials of what we use uh
Caption: RAM in memory CPU Cycles like they're
Caption: really cheap the marginal cost of that
Caption: is almost zero
Caption: um so why is software expensive and why
Caption: you know we talked before about the
Caption: trillions of dollars worth of you know
Caption: the cost of software bugs what what
Caption: makes up the expense well I'd say it's
Caption: actually human ability so humans we've
Caption: got limited working memory limited
Caption: cognitive powers and limited reliability
Caption: this kind of links back to the keynote
Caption: this morning when we're talking about
Caption: talking about fallibility of human
Caption: memory in particular so that's just one
Caption: of these things and programming
Caption: languages that adapt for that can
Caption: actually really Empower us ones that
Caption: ignore the humanness uh and and we'll
Caption: see some examples anyway they're
Caption: probably the ones where it's going to be
Caption: harder to express a correct program and
Caption: and increase your rate of bugs
Caption: so how could the programming language
Caption: itself how could the design of it
Caption: actually help with this sort of human
Caption: focus on the programming language
Caption: particularly humans being limited so
Caption: I've just got a whole bunch of examples
Caption: there I just bolted a couple that I
Caption: could just briefly speak to like raising
Caption: the level of abstraction to reduce the
Caption: semantic Gap so
Caption: um we saw before you know literally
Caption: putting in the hex codes you can't
Caption: really look at that and see what the
Caption: program does although I did do an early
Caption: version of this and someone who saw the
Caption: Commodore 64 stuff I know what that does
Caption: because he had one when he and he still
Caption: remembers all the op codes but for most
Caption: of us
Caption: if you see source code you want to see
Caption: something that is kind of human readable
Caption: for most of us in here that's things
Caption: like you know the English keywords and
Caption: visual breakdown of of blocks in the
Caption: code and I put that one there visuality
Caption: use layout and keywords and punctuation
Caption: to actually make you know we can
Caption: recognize patterns visually very very
Caption: quickly so if your source code actually
Caption: allows for that pattern recognition of
Caption: humans by having visually indented and
Caption: delimited blocks we can see that very
Caption: very quickly that works with us it helps
Caption: us to produce software faster and with
Caption: less mistakes and also we what we really
Caption: want to optimize in our code is
Caption: understandability not necessarily making
Caption: source code AS short as possible having
Caption: a language that is the the shortest to
Caption: express or the most minimal language
Caption: like the one with the fewest constructs
Caption: that doesn't necessarily win if it comes
Caption: at the expense of human
Caption: understandability
Caption: so just one quick example for this
Caption: section
Caption: I'd say most of us are pretty familiar
Caption: with basic control flow constructs like
Caption: this so control flow is basically just
Caption: it's an imperative concept for
Caption: imperative languages which are the ones
Caption: I'd say most of us use like Java c-sharp
Caption: things like that you do things in order
Caption: there's a time-based component I do step
Caption: one then I do step two and if that's all
Caption: you could do step one two three you
Caption: could only write a linear logic program
Caption: and it would always terminate depending
Caption: on how long you know just basically how
Caption: many lines you've got if you want things
Caption: that run forever
Caption: um or you know running definitely let's
Caption: say probably you don't want an infinite
Caption: Loop you need control flow constructs
Caption: that can alter the order in which
Caption: statements are executed and these really
Caption: common ones are the top two are Loops so
Caption: you can keep repeating the same series
Caption: of instructions while some condition is
Caption: true or you could Loop over every item
Caption: in a collection so they're really common
Caption: and then the bottom two are conditionals
Caption: so it's like just conditionally execute
Caption: these things if a certain condition is
Caption: true otherwise skip them or look at this
Caption: value and then depending on what it is
Caption: either do this or do this or do this so
Caption: that's like a switch statement pretty
Caption: basic like you know I think we're all
Caption: familiar with that
Caption: but what if I told you we could go even
Caption: simpler what if I told you that a single
Caption: control flow construct could do
Caption: everything all those others do and we
Caption: can just sweep them away and make our
Caption: language even simpler with just one kind
Caption: of control flow well it exists if
Caption: condition go to label
Caption: so
Caption: it just means that you should be able to
Caption: label any line in your code and then you
Caption: can say well if this condition is true
Caption: when you execute this line just jump to
Caption: that other label
Caption: so um I thought I'd give a demonstration
Caption: to show how great this would be I picked
Caption: a modern language that actually still
Caption: allows go to so I was actually able to
Caption: test it and this is working code so I've
Caption: started with a a prime generator that's
Caption: pretty straightforward it basically just
Caption: goes through all the numbers from 1 to
Caption: 100 and then for that number it doesn't
Caption: interloop to try and find something that
Caption: divides into it that excludes it from
Caption: being a prime so if it if it gets
Caption: through that inner loop and it hasn't
Caption: found any divisors then it's still a
Caption: prime and then we just print it to the
Caption: console and that's what it prints out
Caption: one two three five seven and so on up to
Caption: 97. so I just chose that example because
Caption: it's relatively simple but it's got It's
Caption: got loops and it's got conditionals in
Caption: it now I'm going to transform it using
Caption: my awesome 101 only control flow
Caption: construct if condition go to label so
Caption: first of all I get rid of the outer for
Caption: Loop and I've replaced that I needed a
Caption: couple of labels and a couple of new
Caption: go-to statements but it's the same
Caption: program still works the same this is
Caption: this is all valid C sharp then I get rid
Caption: of the inner for Loop then I get rid of
Caption: the first if and then I get rid of the
Caption: second if and now I've got a final
Caption: program that does exactly the same thing
Caption: as the first one but it's way simpler
Caption: because it's only got one control flow
Caption: construct and also we got rid of all
Caption: that weird indenting and now it's all
Caption: nice and straight
Caption: so there's my before and there's my
Caption: after okay it's slightly longer um what
Caption: would you choose in terms of I mean
Caption: we're talking here about human limited
Caption: human cognitive ability right maybe it's
Caption: just my training but I would take the
Caption: one on the left still even though you
Caption: could say it's more complex because it's
Caption: got more different constructs so it's
Caption: not about minimality sometimes it's
Caption: about working with the human the way we
Caption: think I can visually see the loops in
Caption: this one on that one I would basically
Caption: have to run it in my head
Caption: so if you look for pictures of go-to
Caption: people doing go-to programming you often
Caption: find these print these screenshots that
Caption: they've done of some old bit of working
Caption: out where they obviously drawn all over
Caption: the program source code to try and get
Caption: it into their head what's actually going
Caption: on so on the left we've just got these
Caption: you can express any control flow with
Caption: these three constructs sequence
Caption: selection repetition on the right you
Caption: can just use one control flow construct
Caption: but it's actually a lot harder to
Caption: understand
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: um that's probably a good segue into
Caption: this one which is also about the
Caption: humanity The Human Side of of
Caption: programming languages and how to take it
Caption: into account so before we were saying
Caption: don't overburden the human now we're
Caption: saying don't rely on the human because
Caption: even if you make it easy for them humans
Caption: are fallible we make mistakes
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: the main point I want to make in this
Caption: section briefly is that if a programming
Caption: task could be described as a set of
Caption: mechanical transforms then design the
Caption: programming language itself to just
Caption: fully automate that just take it out of
Caption: the hands of the human because we're not
Caption: that good at perfectly reproducing the
Caption: same transformation again and again in a
Caption: manual way I cut I call this the human
Caption: compiler anti-pattern so I don't think
Caption: you'll find that on Google because I
Caption: just made it up
Caption: um but the reason I call it the human
Caption: compiler antipant because I'm thinking
Caption: that you know people even get proud of
Caption: doing this stuff you know it's like wow
Caption: you know I can really reliably create
Caption: this really complicated code
Caption: um but actually what they are doing
Caption: could be automated by the the
Caption: programming language tools themselves
Caption: that's great for this hot shot whoever
Caption: they are you know that's really awesome
Caption: for their self-esteem and so on but
Caption: statistically speaking as an industry
Caption: it's going to increase our error rates
Caption: if we require humans to do that sort of
Caption: stuff so
Caption: um
Caption: let's have a quick look at an example
Caption: that I set up this is Javascript
Caption: and I've just got a function here that
Caption: as it says at the top it returns a
Caption: number of files in a given directory so
Caption: it's a function I pass it in a directory
Caption: path and at the end it's going to return
Caption: me a number which is how many files not
Caption: directories but files in there and the
Caption: way it works is by making a couple of
Caption: system calls one is to get a list of all
Caption: the files in the directory and it just
Caption: gives the short names of the files not
Caption: the full paths so then we have to map
Caption: them to full paths and then we can go
Caption: and make another series of system called
Caption: one per file and get the stats and the
Caption: stats will tell us if it's a file or a
Caption: directory and then we've got all the
Caption: information we need to count up the
Caption: files in the directory so I think that's
Caption: pretty
Caption: um pretty straightforward and I just
Caption: wanted to highlight that this is in a
Caption: sync function and we use a weight I
Caption: don't want to go into all the ins and
Caption: outs and that I'm hoping that enough of
Caption: you understand a bit about asynchronous
Caption: programming to just you know if you if
Caption: you came into JavaScript or another
Caption: language with a sync await in the last
Caption: say five years I think that's hopefully
Caption: fairly easy to understand but async away
Caption: is another one of these things that is
Caption: an innovation that wasn't always around
Caption: what came before sink away what was
Caption: being required of the programmer before
Caption: it sort of took care of these
Caption: concurrency patterns for us
Caption: well
Caption: when I first started using node it was
Caption: on the Zero Point X version number
Caption: JavaScript it was always running on
Caption: JavaScript on V8 but JavaScript at the
Caption: time didn't have a sink away it didn't
Caption: even have promises so if you wanted to
Caption: do asynchronous operations and node has
Caption: always been fully asynchronous from day
Caption: one you basically say go and start this
Caption: job like go and get the the file stats
Caption: for me and when you're done call this
Caption: callback that I'm going to give you now
Caption: so it's all callback based it's
Caption: basically continuation passing so I've
Caption: got the next slide is this exact same
Caption: program that you would have to write
Caption: manually it's the same program
Caption: you would have to write this out
Caption: manually and manage all the uh the
Caption: callbacks yourself there's a bunch of
Caption: them up there so uh you pass you ask for
Caption: a call back and then you call that call
Caption: back when you've either got an error
Caption: well actually there's all the error
Caption: Pathways so there's several ways that
Caption: you could get errors at different points
Caption: you've now got to manually do all that
Caption: bookkeeping and if you get that wrong
Caption: you might just swallow the error or you
Caption: might just actually return several
Caption: errors like a basic thing about
Caption: functions is that if you call it once
Caption: it's either going to return or it's
Caption: going to throw an exception right the
Caption: only exception to that is like an
Caption: infinite Loop but we won't go into that
Caption: here you've actually got the the
Caption: erroneous possibilities of calling the
Caption: Callback which is the equivalent of
Caption: returning from the function and sending
Caption: back multiple errors or multiple returns
Caption: or even sending back errors and return
Caption: values at the same time there's so many
Caption: ways that this could go wrong but people
Caption: and and I remember you know coming
Caption: across Reddit threads like it's not that
Caption: hard like I'm really good at it I've
Caption: never made any mistakes
Caption: um yeah sure however
Caption: uh this is really just gonna on
Caption: statistically speaking on average that's
Caption: really going to reduce error rates
Caption: across the board right so if the
Caption: compiler can do it it should do it for
Caption: you
Caption: um that does sort of raise the question
Caption: of design patterns because they sort of
Caption: meet that thing of
Caption: um really mechanical transforms on code
Caption: to to handle certain situations that you
Caption: can always apply reliably right
Caption: um so I'm not saying that they're all
Caption: bad but I think it's interesting to look
Caption: at some of the design patterns and
Caption: they're written for specific languages
Caption: some design patterns you really don't
Caption: need to code in a special way depending
Caption: on which language it's in and it's an
Caption: interesting framework to look at design
Caption: patterns that they're not always a great
Caption: idea they might actually be telling you
Caption: that your programming language itself is
Caption: not expressive enough because you've got
Caption: to do this sort of manual transformation
Caption: to get the that kind of code to work
Caption: that's for that's a talk for another
Caption: time so moving on making invalid States
Caption: unrepresentable now this is the section
Caption: that I would want to do the full talk on
Caption: because this is my Jam what I really
Caption: want to talk about here is type systems
Caption: unfortunately I've probably got about
Caption: five minutes to cover this section and
Caption: to motivate this like why would we care
Caption: about type systems how does that fit
Caption: into this whole thing of programming
Caption: language limitations and so on well this
Caption: chart kind of says it all so on this
Caption: chart we've got these bars that get
Caption: bigger to the right um the but the
Caption: bigger the bar the higher the cost to
Caption: repair a defect in software and the
Caption: further to the right you go it may seem
Caption: to mean it means the later the bug was
Caption: discovered so that really tall bar on
Caption: the right is bugs that were discovered
Caption: in production so you've you've crafted
Caption: your piece of software it's gone through
Caption: all your QA it's gone out to customers
Caption: and at that point the bug is discovered
Caption: if you're lucky the bug was discovered
Caption: by your customers and only hopefully a
Caption: few of them and you might have to make
Caption: them whole and that might cost some
Caption: money if you're unlucky it might affect
Caption: all your customers catastrophically with
Caption: whatever Financial losses if you're even
Caption: more unlucky it's not the customers that
Caption: are affected it's it's you that's
Caption: affected because someone has found a
Caption: vulnerability in your code and they've
Caption: found a way to hack the system and cause
Caption: all kinds of other damage like stealing
Caption: information about your customers that
Caption: can be extremely costly so that's I
Caption: think the sort of rationale for why
Caption: there's this pattern of raising costs
Caption: the further out you go catching it
Caption: earlier means catching it in say QC but
Caption: if you've got say a big team of human QC
Caption: testers there's a cost involved in
Caption: having that team right so it's quite
Caption: costly to to be using that team if
Caption: there's whole classes of bugs that you
Caption: could find before it even leaves your
Caption: laptop where you're where you're making
Caption: the software it's even cheaper because
Caption: you never it never goes through those
Caption: later steps right so this is a time when
Caption: it's really cheap to catch bugs the
Caption: cheapest time is when you just catch
Caption: things that are that are wrong in the
Caption: spec before you even write code but
Caption: we're talking about programming
Caption: languages so let's assume the spec is
Caption: correct what can the programming
Caption: language do to actually help you catch
Caption: bugs before they even go out to
Caption: production because it's a lot cheaper to
Caption: catch them there and that's where type
Caption: systems come in by the way this this
Caption: graph really motivates this concept of
Caption: shift left the idea of shift left
Caption: testing is basically looking at this
Caption: graph and saying with all these defects
Caption: and bugs we want to shift to the left
Caption: and catch them way earlier because it
Caption: saves us a lot of trouble uh money and
Caption: time so
Caption: there's a very very strong link between
Caption: most people think of shift left as
Caption: having better unit tests but I think
Caption: there's a really strong link between the
Caption: idea of shift left which is great and
Caption: static type checking because type checks
Caption: are tests they're tests that you don't
Caption: have to write as separate unit tests but
Caption: they will catch bugs for you before you
Caption: even run the code
Caption: so
Caption: good would be that you run some sort of
Caption: build tool and it tells you so I'm
Caption: looking at the top of the screen here
Caption: and it says hey there's these errors in
Caption: your code and you can't take it any
Caption: further you can't run that program you
Caption: can't release it to production you can't
Caption: merge it to main that's great even
Caption: better would be the middle one whereas
Caption: you're just typing in your IDE it's
Caption: already putting up a red squiggle and
Caption: saying hey this isn't right so just as
Caption: you're typing you're already learning
Caption: that there's a bug and you fix it
Caption: straight away super easy and cheap even
Caption: better than that is before you've even
Caption: typed something it tells you what the
Caption: options are so a lot of these powers are
Caption: actually driven by Static type systems
Caption: all of that this this intellisense in
Caption: the bottom that it knows what the valid
Caption: options are because of the type system
Caption: that your programming language has built
Caption: into it most of the time
Caption: um so these are really powerful things
Caption: and type systems are getting really good
Caption: so I think most of us are familiar with
Caption: the old classics classes interfaces and
Caption: then basic types like numbers and
Caption: strings and booleans but if you look out
Caption: there at all the programming languages
Caption: that are being developed between
Caption: research languages functional languages
Caption: there's a lot of languages out there and
Caption: there's a lot of types some of them are
Caption: actually not new like sum and product
Caption: types have been around for decades in
Caption: functional languages
Caption: others are like at the bottom they're
Caption: linear types and affine types don't even
Caption: ask me what that last one is um yeah
Caption: yeah they can get pretty
Caption: um tricky
Caption: and um but there's a there's a richness
Caption: out there now
Caption: um so
Caption: if you want to learn about some of those
Caption: things like me putting on a top where I
Caption: feel like I should have some some sort
Caption: of authority about it uh you can just go
Caption: to YouTube and start googling making
Caption: illegal States unrepresentable and
Caption: there's a whole bunch of videos and
Caption: they'll often be talking about type
Caption: system solutions to this problem of you
Caption: know making illegal States
Caption: unrepresentable basically means the type
Caption: system should pick up errors straight
Caption: away if you've specified
Caption: I don't know um for user first name
Caption: middle name last name first and last
Caption: name are required middle name is
Caption: optional if you can say in the type
Caption: system that if that intent and you can
Caption: see it in the code then you'll catch
Caption: that error straight away if if nulls are
Caption: just implicit in all in all strings then
Caption: you can't specify that intent in the
Caption: code and you can't catch that that error
Caption: until you write a unit test for it or it
Caption: goes out to production and crashes so
Caption: that's what that's what we're really
Caption: talking about making illegal States
Caption: unrepresentable it's a type system thing
Caption: usually
Caption: it can go pretty far so in my wanderings
Caption: I came across this video and I thought
Caption: oh there's a there's a typo in the in
Caption: the video name and then I actually
Caption: started watching the video by the way
Caption: ATS is a research functional language
Caption: that implements linear types and they
Caption: can do amazing things but the guy says
Caption: in the first sentence of his talk he
Caption: says by the way that's not a typo I
Caption: actually meant to say a tase of ATS like
Caption: he said you know it's so difficult to
Caption: get right that it's like being tased so
Caption: you know types there's a trade-off again
Caption: there's a trade-off they can be really
Caption: super powerful but they also mean you
Caption: know you might add complexity to the
Caption: development process along the way that
Caption: brings us to typescript which is a
Caption: language I really love
Caption: type typescript is basically making a
Caption: lot of these Advanced types go
Caption: mainstream because they set as a design
Caption: goal to statically identify constructs
Caption: that are likely to be errors
Caption: encode that already existed in massive
Caption: quantities JavaScript is already out
Caption: there lots of libraries were already out
Caption: there they said how could we actually
Caption: analyze code that already exists that
Caption: people are already writing with all
Caption: sorts of patterns and add this layer
Caption: over the top of that a type system it's
Caption: a superset of JavaScript that can
Caption: actually detect where there's errors in
Caption: the code there's the low hanging fruit
Caption: like just spotting typos in property
Caption: names that's pretty easy right but as
Caption: the project has evolved and matured
Caption: they've added some amazing abilities
Caption: um we're at the point now in typestrip
Caption: where it's probably easier to think of
Caption: the type system as itself a separate
Caption: programming language
Caption: as a programming language I would
Caption: describe it as a DSL or a domain
Caption: specific language it's a language really
Caption: specifically for checking types for
Caption: inferring checking and proving that
Caption: certain type relationships hold
Caption: as a language it's also a purely
Caption: functional language with no side effects
Caption: and it's also Turing complete so you can
Caption: actually compute anything that's
Caption: computable purely at compile time in the
Caption: type system so a pro of that is that
Caption: it's it really enables you to set up
Caption: really really specific static checks so
Caption: you can shift left in all kinds of ways
Caption: you can catch a lot of Errors before you
Caption: even run the program because static
Caption: checks at the end of the day are things
Caption: that you can identify just from looking
Caption: at source code you don't even have to
Caption: run it a downside of type systems that
Caption: are this this rich is that they tend to
Caption: have some pretty weird syntax that's not
Caption: familiar to us and in typescript case
Caption: it's really interesting because a lot of
Caption: the types they actually have the same
Caption: syntax as the the runtime code it
Caption: mirrors but not perfectly so you've
Caption: really got a sort of you've got that
Caption: cognitive load of learning two sets of
Caption: things and a lot of I think for a lot of
Caption: people that don't even recognize the
Caption: same control flow constructs in the type
Caption: system as in the runtime system but
Caption: they're all there
Caption: um I just grabbed one quick example of
Caption: the typescript blog and I just modified
Caption: a little bit for this talk but this is
Caption: basically off their blog so it's not a
Caption: super complicated one but in in
Caption: JavaScript you might just want to have a
Caption: a simple object Watcher where you could
Caption: pass in an object with some properties
Caption: in it and it will return to you a
Caption: version of that object that's still got
Caption: the original properties but it's got a
Caption: couple of callback methods that you can
Caption: attach a callback to and they'll be
Caption: called when one of those properties
Caption: changes
Caption: so I've got an example there if you gave
Caption: it a just an object with an X and A Y in
Caption: their numbers it will give you back an
Caption: object with the X and the Y but also
Caption: it's got an X changed method and a y
Caption: change method and you could put your
Caption: call back in there and get notified If X
Caption: Change and why change super cool and
Caption: this is a dynamic language so it would
Caption: accept any object you like and it will
Caption: set up different different properties
Caption: depending
Caption: um depending on
Caption: um what those that what those property
Caption: names were so we could express the
Caption: runtime code and that's what that make
Caption: watch object is I haven't put the
Caption: runtime code there like that's something
Caption: that most of us could probably figure
Caption: out
Caption: um but the bottom part is a type so
Caption: we've basically got a type level
Caption: function here and we're mapping from
Caption: this the type of the source object which
Caption: typescript can see because if you pass
Caption: in an object there it can see what
Caption: properties it's got and it's going to to
Caption: it's basically a function running at the
Caption: type level it's going to actually call a
Caption: few other type level functions to do a
Caption: calculation of what these new property
Caption: names are going to be and what their
Caption: types are and return that as the output
Caption: type so that that type is actually used
Caption: where it says T and I won't go into the
Caption: details of that but it's basically a
Caption: tight level function so it can do the
Caption: same computation statically as the
Caption: program is doing dynamically so the way
Caption: that works in practice is that you can
Caption: say hey I want to make a watched object
Caption: with first name last name and age so if
Caption: I now go person.on I realize now that my
Caption: my previous slide had an error and the
Caption: the Callback that it adds is on but it's
Caption: strongly typed for the different um
Caption: strings that you could pass into it so I
Caption: want to listen for changes
Caption: um first name changed and then you can
Caption: supply your callback that's fine because
Caption: that's valid the second two they're
Caption: errors because the first one's saying
Caption: well there's you can't say first name
Caption: has to be first name change and the
Caption: second one's just a plain old typo so
Caption: those are things that before they would
Caption: have just only been discovered at
Caption: runtime and now you can find them at
Caption: compile time and not only that it's not
Caption: rigid you don't have to set up separate
Caption: types for every possible different
Caption: object it's like whatever the shape of
Caption: the object is it will do a type level
Caption: function work out what the the shape of
Caption: this watched object that corresponds to
Caption: will be and this kind of thing this is a
Caption: simple example but with typescript you
Caption: can go way beyond that I would love to
Caption: do a talk on more thing cover more
Caption: things like web servers for example
Caption: um finally has everyone got their
Caption: popcorn ready
Caption: o o versus FP
Caption: so um if this was a conference this
Caption: would be such an interesting and
Caption: um controversial topic I think that um
Caption: language paradigms which we haven't
Caption: really touched on yet that would be
Caption: covered here language paradigms is the
Caption: closest thing our industry has to
Caption: religions
Caption: um it's very dangerous to you know
Caption: you've got to watch what you say
Caption: fortunately for me I realized in running
Caption: through this talk a few times that I
Caption: wouldn't have time to really do it
Caption: justice so sorry guys put the popcorn
Caption: away
Caption: um I did try but I really found that in
Caption: a little five minute window you really
Caption: couldn't do justice
Caption: um to to to to the debate so that one
Caption: you know if that's something that you
Caption: guys are interested in maybe I'll pitch
Caption: it for DDD next year
Caption: um I thought though you know I should at
Caption: least try and find some good trolling
Caption: quotes about
Caption: um the two paradigms you know the funny
Caption: thing was it was super easy to find them
Caption: for object oriented but it was very very
Caption: hard the I could basically only find
Caption: this one sort of meme quote for um
Caption: functional languages
Caption: okay endnote
Caption: in a nutshell
Caption: the things we're interested in program
Caption: and language design in ways that it can
Caption: actually make our lives better and
Caption: easier and safer is convenience we want
Caption: less of these rabbit holes where you get
Caption: lost trying to find a good solution we
Caption: want convenience that we can express
Caption: things at a high level in a reasonable
Caption: amount of time and the way we do that is
Caption: by leveling up human capabilities by
Caption: taking into account human weaknesses
Caption: correctness we just want to like squeeze
Caption: bugs out of the system by Design make
Caption: them less possible to even express by
Caption: shifting left and in particular with
Caption: expressive type systems and I think when
Caption: it come I pitched that we look at things
Caption: that will emerge in the future this is a
Caption: big area I think there's a lot of work
Caption: going on in programming language design
Caption: and finally we need to embrace
Caption: trade-offs so different languages
Caption: express some things better than others
Caption: and it I think it's going to always
Caption: remain the case that we should choose
Caption: the the best programming language for
Caption: the job
Caption: and that's it thank you very much
Caption: thank you very much Troy uh what an
Caption: engaging thought-provoking talk I think
Caption: one of the most gripping of today so
Caption: thank you
Caption: um now we're going to open up the floor
Caption: for questions uh do we have any
Caption: questions for drawing this one
Caption: sorry uh some people would be so
Caption: emotional sorry
Caption: uh buddy
Caption: like it sent off
Caption: try it again
Caption: I can hear you I can hear you next so I
Caption: can repeat your question if you
Caption: hello okay that's better
Caption: um what do you think drives some people
Caption: to be so emotionally attached to a
Caption: certain Paradigm or a certain language
Caption: if you've seen it happen well I think
Caption: it's a like a bit of a Minefield even
Caption: discussing it because I said I made an
Caption: analogy to religion and there's probably
Caption: that there's a deep analogy there so I
Caption: would say
Caption: um some sometimes it's you've you've
Caption: grown up knowing one thing all your life
Caption: and it's very difficult to hear things
Caption: that say you're wrong
Caption: and or even if you came to a certain way
Caption: of say developing software in a certain
Caption: Paradigm yourself you may have invested
Caption: a lot in in doing it that way and maybe
Caption: people with really different views from
Caption: you just um
Caption: you know it's risky to to embrace new
Caption: ideas sometimes because you've invested
Caption: a lot in what you already know and
Caption: typically no idea is perfect so you can
Caption: always Point flaws in the other people's
Caption: way of looking at the world
Caption: so a little bit of resistance to change
Caption: and fear of the unknown I think so yeah
Caption: thanks
Caption: any other question
Caption: that's great thank you everyone
Caption: um lunch is served out in the foyer
Caption: and a big round of Records to try
Caption: [Applause]